cuando hacemos sumas o restas juntamos o
quitamos cosas al sumar 2 más 2 juntamos
dos cosas por ejemplo si tenemos dos
pelotas y ponemos otras dos entonces
tenemos 1 2 3 4 así que en total tenemos
4 como resultado de la suma recuerda que
este es el signo que nos dice que vamos
a hacer una suma y que debemos agregar o
poner cosas este otro signo es el de la
resta y nos dice que debemos de quitar
algo cuando tenemos una suma que
reconocemos por el signo demás debemos
de juntar las dos cantidades por ejemplo
3 4 1 2 3 y del otro lado 1 2 3 4 si los
juntamos tenemos 1 2
4 5 6 7 por lo tanto tenemos como
resultado 7 34 es igual a 7 esto lo
podemos hacer más rápido si solo
contamos el segundo grupo de los números
vamos a tomar el primer número en este
caso el 3 y de ahí seguimos 4 5 6 y 7
contamos cuatro lugares porque debemos
agregar 4 al 3 al avanzar estos 4
lugares de 3 4 llegamos al 7 así que 3 4
es igual a 7 hagamos otro ejemplo de
suma si tenemos 5 3 como los sumas lo
que yo haría sería contar tres números o
tres lugares después del 5 empiezo con
el 5 y sigo 6 7 y 8 y llego al resultado
de la suma que es 8 ya vimos una manera
muy fácil de hacer sumas ahora veamos
que debemos hacer si queremos quitar
elementos utilizando la resta hay dos
formas diferentes de hacerlo si tenemos
la red
6 2 podemos hacer como en las sumas pero
al revés es decir en lugar de contar y
agregar de uno en uno vamos a ir
quitando de uno en uno
empezamos con el 6 y vamos hacia atrás
dos lugares 6 5 y 4 entonces 6 menos 2
es igual a 4 vamos a ver otro ejemplo te
invito a que intentes resolverlo antes
de que te lo explique cuánto es 8 menos
5 pausa el vídeo e intenta resolverlo
cuando tengas la respuesta continúa con
el vídeo para saber si tu resultado fue
el correcto usando el mismo camino hacia
atrás tenemos 8 y después 7 6 5 4 3 y 3
es nuestro resultado después de
retroceder cinco lugares 85 es 3
la otra forma de resolver las restas es
tomar el segundo número y ver cuántos
lugares nos faltan para que sea igual
que el primero en el ejemplo de 6 menos
2 sería contar cuántos lugares hay del 2
al 6 y comenzamos a contar 3 4 5 6 son 4
lugares entonces 6 menos 2 es igual a 4
para el caso de 8 5 empezamos a contar
en el 5 y avanzamos 6 7 y 8 fueron 3
lugares así que 85 es igual a 3 hagamos
algunos ejercicios rápidos 6 + 2
entonces contamos 6 7 y 8 y colocamos 8
en el resultado después 5 más 1 contamos
un lugar después del 5 y llegamos al 6
ahora
7 - 6 si contamos desde el 6 tenemos 6 y
7 o sea un lugar así que el resultado es
18 menos 1 aquí lo haremos como el
primer método de contar hacia atrás
tenemos 8 y un lugar hacia atrás es 7
el resultado es 7 sigue siendo cuentas
de este tipo y agrega o quita los
números en tu mente verás que es
divertido y que cada vez a las sumas y
restas más rápido